Visitors from around the world...
...paid their respects along this section of Hollywood Boulevard...
...which is lined with sidewalk plaques to the major stars, including Robin Williams.
One found the news hard to believe Monday, after a friend sent a message.
My reaction was like, "This has to be a joke."
"It has to be a joke, no way."
As the news sank in, fans looked back on the actor's varied career,...
...including Melinda Martinez.
He was just an amazing actor and comedian and I'm very touched,...
...and I was very saddened yesterday like probably the whole world.
Williams rose to fame more than 30 years ago.
Many fans grow up with Williams' work like Daniel Hammond of New Zealand.
He was a big part of my childhood, I think, growing up,...
...a lot of the movies like silly kind of kids' movies, "Jumanji" and things...
...were a big part of my childhood and it's really sad to see him go.
Charlene Houdashell, a visitor from Texas, loved the comic's upbeat humor.
He always seemed to be able to make everybody else laugh...
...and forget about whatever problems they had in their life.
Others like John Linville loved his spontaneity.
He's off-the-cuff, he's very quick.
He's quick with it.
You know, he can come up with ideas very, very fast.
The actor won an Oscar for a serious role.
Robin Williams in "Good Will Hunting."
Some fans prefer the actor's many comic roles, including German visitor Angelique Hoffman.
Because I think that there are less actors who can brighten up the day...
...and make movies that kind of special that people remember it.
These fans say Robin Williams will be remembered as an actor...
...who brought laughter and entertainment to millions of people.
Michael Sullivan, VOA News, Los Angeles.